THAT TASK FORCE BRIEFING TONIGHT
COMING UP AT P.M.
STATEMENT WILL BE THERE FOR THAT
THAT.
GILLIAN TURNER, THANK YOU.
LET’S BRING IN ARI FLEISCHER.
IS THE FORMER PRESS WORKER.
WHEN YOU GET THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION INVOLVED, THERE IS
A LOT OF SKEPTICISM ACROSS
AMERICA WHEN IT COMES TO THIS
ORGANIZATION.
IS IT WARRANTED IN THIS CASE?
>> YES AND NO.
THIS IS A CLASSIC AND BABIES AND
BATHWATER ISSUE.
THERE’S A LOT THAT W.H.O.
DOESN’T POOR COUNTRIES AROUND
THE WORLD THAT’S VERY HELPFUL.
WHEN IT COMES TO WORK IN THE
MORE SOPHISTICATED AND MODERN
COUNTRIES, IT’S NOT AS
INFLUENTIAL OR HELPFUL.
NUMBER ONE, THEY ACKNOWLEDGED
AND PASSED AROUND CHINESE
STATEMENTS SAYING THERE IS NO
HUMAN TO HUMAN TRANSMISSION OF
CORONAVIRUS IN MID AND LATE
JANUARY AND THEY ALSO CRITICIZED
THE UNITED STATES FOR SHUTTING
DOWN FLIGHTS TO CHINA.
BOTH OF THOSE WERE ERRORS IN
JUDGMENT OR JUST ERRORS, THEY
DESERVE CRITICISM FOR THAT.
>> Dana: AND FUNDING IS
SOMETHING THAT THE
UNITED STATES, WE FOUND A LOT OF
THINGS ACROSS THE WORLD AND WE
USUALLY DO MORE OF OUR LINE
CHAIR.
ONE THING WE SHOULD SEE, SHOULD
THE UNITED STATES HAVE MORE OF A
SAY IN THE UNITED NATIONS IF WE
ARE GOING TO GET FUNDING IT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WE FUND TO SO MANY INTERNATIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS, WAY BEYOND WHAT
ANY OTHER ORGANIZATION DOES AND
THE NATIONS USE OUR MONEY TO
KICK US AND CRITICIZE US.
WE SEEM TO ROLL OVER AND TAKE IT
IT.
WHEN THIS IS OVER, ONE OF THE
THINGS WE HAVE TO DO IS HAVE A
SECOND LOOK AT A LOT OF
DIFFERENT INSTITUTIONS.
NOT TO POLITICIZE BUT TO SAY
WHAT COULD BE DONE BETTER.
THAT INCLUDES W.H.O. AND
INCLUDES THE CDC AND INCLUDES
THE FDA.
THERE’S A WHOLE LOT THAT WE HAVE
TO LEARN FROM THIS TO DO BETTER
AND IT W.H.O. IT HAS GOT TO BE
OPEN AND ACCESSIBLE TO TELL WHAT
THEY’VE DONE AND NOT CALL IT
POLITICIZATION AND TRY TO GET
OUT OF IT BY DISMISSING IT.
>> Dana: POLITICIZATION IS THE
WORST WORD.
I WISH WE HAD A DIFFERENT WORD
BECAUSE IT BOTHERS ME, I CAN’T
EVER SAY IT CORRECTLY.
BUT YOU DID IT JUST RIGHT.
TALKING ABOUT POLITICS, AND WANT
TO MOVE TO THIS BECAUSE TODAY
BERNIE SANDERS DECIDED HE’S
GOING TO CALL IT QUITS.
BUT HE DID SAY HE WANTS TO
REMAIN ON THE BALLOTS SO HE CAN
CONTINUE TO ACCUMULATE DELEGATES
SO HE CAN HAVE SOME INFLUENCE
OVER THE DNC CONVENTION.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> THE INFLUENCE HE SAID HE
WANTS IS ON THE PLATFORM
COMMITTEE AND I SUBMIT TO YOU
THAT HE ALREADY HAS HAD
TREMENDOUS INFLUENCE ON THE
BIDEN COMMITTEE.
HE HAS MOVED TO JOE BIDEN SO FAR
TO THE LEFT, POSITIONS THAT
JOE BIDEN USED TO FIGHT AGAINST,
HE NOW FIGHTS FOR BECAUSE OF
BERNIE SANDERS.
HE WANTS A PUBLIC OPTION ON
HEALTH CARE.
GOVERNMENT RUN HEALTH CARE.
HE WAS OPPOSED TO THAT WHEN HE
WAS BARACK OBAMA’S
VICE PRESIDENT AND HE NOW WANTS
THE GREEN NEW DEAL.
HE WANTS FREE COLLEGE.
HE DOESN’T WANT TO DEPORT ANY
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS WHO COMMITTED
FELONIES.
ALL OF THESE ARE POSITIONS ON
THE FAR, FAR LEFT OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY BROUGHT TO YOU
SPONSORED BY BERNIE SANDERS AND
PROUDLY ADOPTED BY JOE BIDEN.
>> Dana: RIGHT.
HIS MOVEMENT DID HAVE SOME
IMPACT.
NOW I’M WONDERING ABOUT THIS.
FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA HAS SET
IT OUT AND SAID HE PROBABLY
WOULDN’T COMMENT UNTIL THIS WAS
ALL OVER AND NOW THAT JOE BIDEN
IS A PRESUMPTIVE NOMINEE, DO YOU
EXPECT TO SEE PRESIDENT OBAMA
MAY BE WEIGHING IN NOW?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IF IT WAS A NORMAL YEAR AND YOU
COULD TRAVEL, IT WOULD BE A
GIGANTIC OBAMA-BITE IN THE
EVENT.
A HUGE CELEBRATION AND A BURNING
MIGHT BE THERE AS WELL, THEY
HOLD HANDS AND HAVE A UNIFIED
APPEARANCE.
THAT’S COMING.
WE JUST DON’T KNOW WHAT DAY.
WILL THEY CREATE A VIRTUALLY OR
DO IT IN PERSON, IT’S COMING.
>> Dana: IT WILL BE A REALLY